[Music]
people always say that the girls of this
generation are so vain
why can't they put their brains towards
books instead of good looks i used to
blame girls too
be more than a perfect body with a
pretty hairdo and then i stepped out
into the world i opened my eyes to the
truth about being a girl i heard guys
say things like dude she was 10 times
tighter than that girl you hit
and quit rey or i want to pipe your
sister someday
or her ass looks like a racetrack with
those stretch marks but
at least it's big like kim k's i never
grew up thinking of those things don't
blame me but when i thought about boys i
thought about
dinner dates and soul mates not [ __ ]
boys that look at you like shark bait
it breaks my heart for every girl
growing up in this world
instead of how was your day messages we
get you
up wanna come [ __ ] i am not an object i
have a voice and something to say
do not assume that i belong in your
bedroom i belong in a conference room
and for anyone who thinks that this
generation is so vain
it's because us girls have been held
under a microscope day-to-day it's like
beautiful doesn't even exist unless you
can cross
everything off the checklist big butt
big boobs skinny waist includes small
nose plump lips bony hips
hairless careless but still has an
awareness in all fairness i want to be
seen as beautiful too
i mean i don't want to be demeaned i
mean i'm not the same girl i was at 15
i mean i'm stuck in between being a girl
and a woman growing up in a world that
has taught me to look
sexy get a degree maybe a little
rhinoplasty
but never disagree with misogyny a world
that has not taught me that being a
woman
is living in fear that your basic health
care will disappear
or that your paycheck might somehow be
smaller than a man that does the same
job or that your boss might tell you to
stop giving him [ __ ] eyes
if you want to raise you gotta
compromise show me what lies above those
thighs
boy please the moment you misidentified
everything
was when you forgot that not even a
hundred years ago i could not
vote look at what happens when you try
to demote the very bodies that give
birth to you please
we are used to it all and we are
appalled but you see
we don't know what it's like to be free
equality is not just about calling
someone out
equality is accountability that my
brother knows that i am equal to him so
equality is education
from classrooms to courtrooms to
conference rooms and computer screens
it is using tech for good for me too for
movements
equality is truth is strong voices
is breaking through the silence that
exists because silence can't exist if
it's not tolerated
it is all of you changing the future
clearing the path for every woman
and every man it is raising the next
generation to know that not only does
their voice matter but
it will be heard and that's why we got
the power in our hands because we will
not sit back
and nod and smile while certain people
reconcile the rules to being fertile
sorry but it's my body baby i may be a
young lady but my dad always taught me
to speak out and fight against injustice
of every kind
so here i am speaking out for all my
ladies in the house we will not stop the
fight until we hold our rights
for women of every color size shape
sexual identity and place in this world
and that is the truth about being a girl
[Music]
you